[Music]
Kali is in Richmond Virginia hi Kelly
how are you you better than I deserve
what's up I'm Fletcher Total Money
Makeover back in January and I loved it
I was upset I was ready to go but my
husband has been an entirely different
story what is your suggestion on getting
spouses involved why they have to be
here you're not going to win it's going
to continue to cause problems I stay at
home yeah it's gonna I'm sorry
especially since I stay at home he's an
income provider yeah well that doesn't
matter what matters is is that this is
going to continue to be a thorn in the
side of your relationship and you're not
going to win with money until you're
doing it together and so those are two
reasons that this needs to be fixed so
why did you read the Total Money
Makeover book what was it that prompted
you to do that like I said we're single
income family and we have two kids
and I don't want them to have to
struggle or watch us struggle as they
get older so you are in rug lling we are
doing a little bit better now I I
convinced him to do a little bit he sold
his car since he really didn't need it
so we got rid of one payment and it's
slowly tackling the debt okay what does
he do for a living
he's a police officer okay how old are
you guys 27 okay how long has you been a
police officer for seven years as he has
he been on patrol during that time yes
sir okay well I think what I you know
what I'm going to do is this if I'm in
your shoes I think you kind of threw the
book at him in a sense no pun intended
and said Dave Ramsey says do this and
we're stupid if we don't do it and so if
you don't agree you're stupid and my
name becomes a cuss word in your house
and he goes back to work that's probably
what happened or some version of that
maybe you weren't quite that rough but
you don't sound like you're that rough
but a lot of people do that type of a
thing so instead what I would do is come
around and start talking about what we
need to do I would talk about why we
need to do it that's why I asked you why
you read the book and you said because I
don't want to struggle with two kids I
don't want them to see us struggle I
want to change our family tree I want us
to get in control okay so what if the
conversation sounded like this you say
to him you know I you know you're the
love of my life this is our marriage is
everything to me I'm so proud of you
being a police officer and this the
information this book meant a lot to me
not because of Dave Ramsey not because
of the book but it meant a lot to me
honey because I don't want our kids to
see a struggle and that's why I read the
book I don't want us to struggle I want
us to succeed financially and I want you
to continue to live out your dream of
being an officer and honey I am positive
because I am positive by the way that
and when you go on a domestic call when
he goes into a car which is by the way
one of the most dangerous calls a
policeman goes into where there's a
demand domestic argument husband and
wife are fighting and they call the
police right very dangerous very
dangerous um but when he goes in there
you know what he sees
90% of the time he sees a money fight
between the couples and just got when
you go on a domestic call you know how
often it's around money there's an
argument about something having to do
with money the number one calls a
divorce I read in this book is money
fights and money problems and so the
number one way we can be have a super
successful marriage and be successful
with money's to be on the same page so
honey it would mean everything to me you
would be telling me you'd be shouting at
me how much you love me if you would
just read this and that's why I want you
to do it not because I'm nagging you but
because of all those reasons kid can you
recap something like I just said to him
that'll go a long way because we're
talking about why rather than we're
stupid with money we don't have enough
money we're single income family sell
your car
yes you know he wanted to do that I know
but you see what I'm I'm overstating it
but I'm also he's riding around patrol
car all day long and that's a little bit
of what he hears yeah
instead of like I'm the man of the house
I can square my shoulders with my wife
beside me and we can fight anything if
we do it together and let's go make some
money and put some money away and build
some wealth let's do this thing
and you know when he hears that this guy
this guy's a knight in shining armor I
know that because it's what he does for
a living he serves and protects that's
what he does he wouldn't have taken that
job for the money it's too dadgum
dangerous he didn't take that job he
took that job because he's an honour
based man am i right yeah and if you
call that out in him I'm not
manipulating him I'm just saying this is
the way to communicate with this man
because that man that's how that man is
wired you're married to a good man you
really are and I'm honored that we get
to help you in some way here so yeah do
that and then I want you guys as my gift
to say thank you to him for serving the
way he is in the community I want the
two of you to go through Financial Peace
University as my gift it is a one-year
membership online and you go to the
local group and take the class take that
go through the with the local group you
go through nine lessons and you get
every dollar plus for one year as well
this is like $300 worth of stuff in this
membership and we only charge 129 for it
and you are paying nothing for it it's
my gift to you to say thank you to him
for serving his community if you get him
to the class I'll give this to you for
free so hold on I'll have Kelly pick up